el líbano ha superado ya los 2.000 casos
de contagios diarios de coronavirus y
las muertes ascienden a unas 800 por la
pandemia por lo general el líbano tiene
deficiencia de camas hospitalarias y
ahora además se suma que los cuatro
principales hospitales de beirut
resultaron seriamente dañados por la
explosión del puerto el 4 de agosto y
todavía no están a pleno rendimiento
para que la cosa no se vaya de las manos
las autoridades libanesas han decretado
dos semanas de confinamiento que
comienza hoy y un toque de queda desde
las 5 de la tarde hasta las 5 de la
mañana todos los comercios no esenciales
están cerrados es decir desde bares
restaurantes centros comerciales hasta
instituciones públicas y centros
educativos desde las guarderías hasta
las universidades la medida también
afecta a la movilidad y únicamente
podrán circular vehículos con matrícula
para un día y al día siguiente vehículos
con matrícula impar muchos comerciantes
temen que el confinamiento se pueda
alargar un tiempo y esto será un duro
a la economía local que ya está
sufriendo seriamente por la crisis